il est encore présent à l'entrée
pourtant ce label n'a pas été renouvelé
depuis dix ans europe direct yvelines
avait pour objectif d'informer les
habitants du département sur le
fonctionnement et les dispositifs de
l'union européenne le président de la
structure qui gère une trentaine de
points et bureau information jeunesse a
son explication
la raison officielle c'est un dossier
très bon mais que nous touchions trop
spécifiquement public de jeunes et sur
la belle ne concerne pas que les jeunes
je crois que c'est plutôt une question
économique de leur part c'est qu'ils
avaient deux structures dans le
département qui portait ce label une
saint germain en laye la maison de
l'europe et nous est manifestement la
commission européenne va faire un choix
de rationalisation et de ne retenir
qu'une seule structure dans le
département il vit une information
jeunesse continuera à informer sur
l'europe grâce à son autre label euros
desk qui s'adresse aux jeunes et qui est
centré sur les questions de mobilité
pour 2018 le manque à gagner de 25 mille
euros sur les trois cent mille euros de
budget annuel malgré tout la structure
est confiante c'est beaucoup
de d'autant plus que le reste des
subventions globalement est quand même
sur une pente descendante assez forte ça
nous oblige aussi à nous recentrer sur
nos missions à nous organiser aussi bien
repenser les missions donc c'est
consolidera n'y a pas d'inquiétude
là-dessus on va continuer à faire des
missions mais ça nous oblige à être plus
sélectifs dans nos actions yveline
information jeunesse souhaite notamment
encore plus développé cette année les
interventions en milieu scolaire ou
encore les opérations comme le service
civique dating en octobre dernier qui a
permis à 50 jeunes de signer un contrat